Pewds: Hey, how's it going? I have collected some
of the finest animation you have ever seen.
*Oh lets see what Pooppiepie prepared for us today!
Pewds: If you have glasses then put them on
right now, if you happen to have a wine
*umh no*
next to you the-then take a big old
slurp.
*Slurp sound*
Let's watch
*Marina joyce overload*
Why did I choose to add CC for this
*Holy mama*
*That was too much man.*
*Rip Poopewpie*
*RIP everyone*
*#SaveMarinaJoyice if u cry everytime,..*
What is this, Marina Joyce animation but...
*Yeh... its..*
There's nothing weird about it I don't understand
*Yah its.. its totally fine...grea.. great animation*
Marina: Dancing inspires me most in life, it makes me feel good, it makes me incredible.
Next video!
*Yeh..*
Video mom: Hello Jimmy I love you
I am going to make a delicious dinner meal.
*Shots fired*
*I rate dis 8/10 cuz there is no scarce meme*
Video dad: Jimmy your mom is dead. Do an order of pizza for dinner.
Jimmy!
No....
*Poor Jimmy*
Now it is time for father son bonding.
*Don't do it JIMMY*
BONDWITHMEJIMMY
Pewds: Its da PIZZA!
Here's your pizza.
Pewds: Great..
Guy: Da pizza is aggressive
Old sheiit...*
Pikachu: The pizza is aggressive...
Oh shit...*
*Wow I can't stop watching this animation..*
Pewds: Don't you just hate it when your dad dies from an aggressive pizza...
Jimmy Nutrient: Just another day in the
life of Jimmy Nutrient
Pewds: Animation is a wonderful thing you can create whatever you want.
Some people decided to make
this
*No i don't want to know what this is..*
*NO NO NOT THERE...*
*._. humantiy is so fucked up..*
Poods: OHHH!! Wow... Ohhh....
Poop: Someone found the footage of my child birth
#Exposed
Pewds: That baby's gonna make it big 1d..
Pewds: Oh shiet.. he got a lady
*idk anymore..*
Pewpoopie: She almost got a big nose as I had..
Pewds: Great.. they are nak-.. great.. Just
Poods: NOOOOOOOOOOO!
*So romantic..*
Pewds: Shit.....
Pewds: Well.. nothing gonna top that one...
*I rate it 10/10*
Jesus...christ man
Pewds: Bhutan Ap Bokto, Bhutan Animation Entertainment
Pewds: The first ever 3D animation film produced in Bhuton.
Pewds: Wtf is Bhotan
Savage Ainsley: Hey check your privilege you blonde head ball bag I am from Bhuton...
Pewds: That's where you are from..? You're from Bhuton?
Poor Ainsley: Yes I was born there nine years before...
Dragon Warrior Bhutan took my family from me a great priest cast his spell
Pewds: Oh wow...
Oh wow..
Its a kingdom...
By china..
*RIP HEADPHONE USERS*
*Tf is dat..*
Dancing poods.mp3
Wow felix great moves, keep it up, proud of ya
*Hi Ainsley*
*Um why are u looking at meh?*
*Umh.... its kinda uncomfortable ya know...*
*OH GAWD NO*
Help us POODS*
THOSE DANCE MOVES
HOLY MOLY THAT WAS "LIT*
Pewds: Oh I love this one.
Pewds: I love the song..
Pewds: This animation is made in 5 fps..
Oh..
OHH...
Pewds: It's too fast
RIP Pikachu 2016 trump will take over now..*
Oh and here goes ainsley ):..
*RIP*
Pewds: Look at them tittes
Go left and right..
Wow
Moment of silence for papa pewds..
DAMMMMMMMMMMMMMM
Pewds: Noo...
Papa poods: Why?
*I'm dying send help to www.youtube.com/GreenPewdiepie*
Pewds:why do I get sexual undertones on this..
Oh....*
*I guess we all know what will happen next...HELP US GOD*
NOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO! U DESTROYED MY WHOLE CHILDHOOD PAPA POODS RIP
HELP US AINSLEY...
HOLY...*
Is this no man's sky 2?
Pewds mind: Well den... i guess jacob sartoruis is good after all.
Pewds: he has a good polish i gotta say..
Pewds: Ok this is a lil better content.
someone made this animation by
themselves to announce that they're
getting a baby let's just watch
UMH.... OK
BABE BABE BABE AHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH BABE BABE BABE AHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH!
RIP
NOOO
Pewds leafy sex.mp3
*Wow this is so good PROUD OF YA*